من عمان لواء فائز الدويري الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجيه دكتور فايز الدويري قراءه
في بدايه في تطورات الاخيره في المشهد
الاوكراني
يعني المشهد الاوكراني منذ اسابيع تحولت
اليه اداره المعركه فبعد ان القى الشيخ
فصل الشتاء بضلاله وفرض تحديدات كبيره على
اجراء عمليات عسكريه
تعرضيه تحتاج الى حركه من نقطه الى اخرى
لمهاجمه اهداف نجد ان ما يقال لستك
اوبريشنز العمليات شبه الثابته هي السائده
والمهيمنه باستثناء همم منطقه باخمد
وبالتالي ما هو البديل البديل تمثل في
استخدام القدرات الصاروخيه والطائرات
المسيره من الجانبين وان كانت المقارنه من
الجانب الاوكراني بصوره محدوده جدا الجانب
ال- همم الروسي بصوره كبيره وخلال ال- ال-
الاسبوع تقريبا الماضي همم
لاحدنا شيء مهم وهو تكيف استخدام الطائرات
لماذا
لانه هناك مبدا في اداره وتع- في اداره
منظومات الدفاع الجوي ان يعمل الجانب
المهاجم بما يسمى
اغراق القدرات الدفاعيه لوحدات الدفاع
الجوي باهداف جويه كبيره جدا لا يستطيع
التعامل مع معظمها وبالتالي ينجح بعض بعض
هذه المسيرات او الصواريخ بالوصول الى
اهدافها عندما يطلق 20 طائره على سبيل
المثال على العاصمه قال لا يستطيع ان يسقط
اكثر من 70 الى 80% وبالتالي ستصل بعد هذه
الطائرات اذا نحن الان امام حرب استنزاف
باستخدام الطائرات المسيره والقسم
الصاروخي وفي الميدان الشرقي وجنوب النهار
باستخدام المدعيه وقذفات الصواريخ وهنا
يطرح سؤال اذا كانت هي حرباء من الفائز
بها المبدا يقول
فائز ليس الاقوى ولكن الفائز الذي لديه
القدره على تامين الامداد لوجستي
والعملياتي حتى الجانب الضعيف في استطاع
اللواء فايز حتى نصل الى
الفائز من يتحمل المسؤوليه عن كن ما يجلى
الان من يتحمل المسؤوليه هذا سؤال كبير
جدا اشكرك يعني الان تتحمل القيادات
السياسيه التي هي الحرب تبدا على طاوله
السياسي وتنتهي على طاوله السياسي ولا
يوجد حرب في التاريخ الا انتهت باتفاق اذن
عندما تكون الاراده السياسيه تتجه باتجاه
الهاء العربي وهناك توجه جد تتوقف المدافع
ويتوقف العسكري عن استخدام قدراته في
اداره المعركه وفي
المعارك اذا هنا السؤال يطرح على
السياسيين هل هناك توجهه دعيني اجي اجيب
بيبي مختصر الرئيس الروسي يريد ان يفرض
ارادته وانه القادر على حجم الحرب
والاحتفاظ بما لديه من الاراضي الاوكرانيه
الغربي يرفض ذلك
ويطمح بصوره
الروسي
واخداعه واجباره على تقديمه تنازلات هنا
نجد لا تزال الفجوه كبيره جدا بين التوجه
السياسي الامريكي والغربي وبين التوجه
السياسي الروسي ما الذي يغير الموقف
انجازات الميدان اذا اقتنع عن رئيس الروسي
انه غير قادر على تحقيق الاهداف في هذه
الحاله سيخضع ويقدم تنازله ولكن هذا
يقابله حتى يخضع ويقدم التناسلات على
الغرب انا اتحدث هنا في ناحيه تحليليه ان
يستمر في تقديم الدعم في ابعاده الشامله
سواء الدفاع الجوي او الذخائر او
البطاريات اللي مارس او حتى قد يحتاجه مع
مطلع الربيع وذوبان الثلوج الى التقدير
الى عمليات بريه
بالطائرات ثابت الثناء والدبابه
العسكري والاستراتيجي من عمان